Ніби професійна ведуча зіркового телешоу - голова Єврокомісії Урсула фон дер Ляєн
особисто провела міжнародну донорську конференцію для збору пожертв на боротьбу з коронавірусом,
зокрема на розробку загальнодоступної вакцини для щеплення.
Першим донором став Євросоюз, пообіцявши один мільярд євро.
Упродовж наступних годин щедрі обіцянки надходять від глав держав,
організацій та компаній з усього світу:
"500 мільйонів доларів від Саудівської Аравії!"
Поп-ікона Мадонна буквально в останню хвилину розщедрилась на один мільйон євро.
Зрештою очікування організаторів майже виконані.
Фінальна сума мінімально не дотягує до запланованих 7,5 мільярдів євро.
Але це - важливий сигнал, заявила голова Єврокомісії:
Сьогодні визначний момент для глобальної спільноти.
Сидячи один від одного далі, ніж зазвичай, світ показав, що став згуртованішим, ніж будь-коли.
Хоча згуртувалися не всі.
Китайський делегат не анонсував жодних пожертв.
Сполучені Штати і Росія узагалі залишились осторонь від конференції.
Генсек ООН Антоніу Гутерреш назвав результат недостатнім.
Аби вакцини вистачило усім жителям планети, світ мусить зібрати уп'ятеробільше грошей.
Гроші призначаються міжнародним організаціям та дослідним центрам
на прискорення розробки вакцини для протидії новому коронавірусу.
Оптимістичні сигнали від науковців з тієї чи іншої країни надходять чи не щодня.
Так, наприкінці квітня стартували клінічні випробування вакцини від COVID-19 у Німеччині.
Хід розробки вселяє в нас велику надію.
Хоча не варто очікувати, що вакцина для масового використання мільйонами людей
з'явиться в нас вже цього року.
Вчені працюють у безпрецедентному ритмі та без вихідних, особливо у Китаї та США.
Створення вак цин у минулому тривало 5-10 років.
Нині амбітна мета науковців з різних країн - встигнути за один рік.
Ми працюємо цілодобово, у кілька змін.
Це суттєво скорочує час, необхідний для створення вакцини.
І демонструє потужність Китаю.
Однак втиснутися у один-два місяці неможливо. Пояснімо, чому.
Спочатку вчені розшифровують генетичну формулу вірусу.
Потім зі складових вірусу та додаткових речовин створюють можливу вакцину.
Наступний крок - вакцину випробовують на тваринах.
У разі успіху дію речовини досліджують на людях.
Далі - процес отримання дозволів.
У ЄС цим займається європейська агенція з лікарських засобів.
І ось тоді, нарешті, може розпочатися масове виробництво вакцини.
Вже понад 80 компаній та держустанов розробляють вакцину від Covid-19.
Деякі лабораторії, зокрема у США, "перестрибнули" етап випробувань на тваринах
і одразу ж почали тестувати речовину на добровольцях.
Результат буде у че рвні.
При цьому створити вакцину вчені намагаються різними шляхами:
Експерименти із живою вакциною роблять ставку на відомі,
нешкідливі, так звані "векторні віруси".
В них "вшивають" частинку генів збудника Sars-Co-v2.
Як наслідок, утворюється така ж сама білкова оболонка, що й в коронавірусу.
Цей "перевдягнений" вірус не може завдати шкоди людям,
але імунна система прищеплених реагує все одно та виробляє антитіла.
І організм тепер "знає", як захиститися від справжнього вірусу.
Дехто розробляє мертву вакцину, тобто з частин деактивованого коронавірусу.
Така модель застосовується у розробці щеплень від правця або грипу.
Однак цим методом швидко створити велику кількість вакцини неможливо.
Найновіший тип вакцини - на базі генів.
Для цього вилучається РНК вірусу, так би мовити, схема його побудови.
Вакцина викликає в організмі створення вірусних білків -
імунна система реагує антитілами.
Однак поки ще немає жодної офіційно дозволеної вакцини цього типу.
На тлі кризи багато сподівань покладається на швидку появу вакцини.
Але це ще не означатиме кінець пандемії.
Є ймовірність мутації вірусу, тобто, його генетичної зміни.
В такому разі вакцина може раптом не працювати.
Наприклад, проти вірусів грипу щороку розробляється нова вакцина.
І вже раніше відомі коронавіруси виявляли здатність до мутації.
У збудника Covid-19 під час нинішньої пандемії мутацій майже не помічали.
І все ж, вчені намагаються працювати на випередження.
Чим швидше з'явиться вакцина, тим більше людей буде врятовано.